[Música]
en medio del Cantar de los pájaros
el sonido de los bombardeos estremece el
cielo de cartón los combates entre el
ejército y un grupo paramilitar rival
continúan a pesar de que ambas partes
anunciaron la prórroga de un alto al
fuego a última hora de acabar el
anterior cese
además de los riesgos para la seguridad
los udaneses que intentan huir a zonas
más seguras tienen que enfrentarse a
problemas logísticos está médico es una
de las que ha conseguido llegar a kosti
en el sur del país
nos dimos cuenta de que los precios de
Los tiquetes de autobús se habían
disparado de menos de 10 dólares a unos
70 dólares por tiquete lo que es una
locura de precio y muchos udaneses ni
siquiera pueden permitírselo
mientras que otros miles huyen hacia
países vecinos al oeste en chat El Éxodo
masivo de su daneses con esta Nueva Ola
de violencia supone una carga adicional
para los escasos recursos que ya estaban
agotados tras albergar a 400.000
refugiados que huyeron del conflicto
anterior en Sudán
en la capital la mayoría de farmacias y
centros médicos están cerrados y el
corte de Electricidad y las gases de
agua afectan a muchos barrios el
suministro de alimentos disminuye
rápidamente
esta panadería una de las pocas abiertas
pronto se quedó sin pan
los lugares que venden harina están
cerrados
Así que no hay suministro para las
panaderías se acabará solo va a empeorar
lo que hay ahora no estará disponible
mañana
Mientras tanto en la región de darfur la
violencia empeoró el jueves los
residentes informaron de enfrentamientos
entre combatientes armados y saqueos de
comercios y viviendas cuando el
conflicto se acerca a su tercera semana